ahora que emanuel macrón queda sin una
mayoría absoluta en los partidos de la
posición en el parlamento buscarán
obstruir su agenda legislativa el poder
que tengan sin embargo dependerá de su
número de escaños se necesitan 15
escaños para crear un grupo
parlamentario como grupo los diputados
tienen más tiempo de intervención en las
preguntas al gobierno también pueden
pedir la suspensión de los debates o
instalarse en una prisión se necesitan
58 diputados para presentar una moción
de censura que inició el debate y luego
una votación si 289 diputados dicen
quien no tienen confianza en el gobierno
el primer ministro debe dimitir si los
diputados no creen que un proyecto de
ley se ajuste a la ley pueden remitir el
asunto al consejo constitucional que
puede rechazar o enmendar un proyecto de
ley para ello se necesitan 60 diputados
esto ocurrió el pasado mes de enero
cuando el consejo valido la mayor parte
de la legislación sobre el pase de la
vacuna contra el coi de los partidos de
la oposición pueden ejercer el control
ocupando puestos de alto nivel como el
del jefe de la comisión de finanzas la
única comisión parlamentaria que debe
estar dirigida por un miembro de la
oposición también pueden auditar los
gastos de los departamentos del gobierno
y llamar a los ministros para
interrogarlos la próxima legislatura a
comenzar al miércoles pero el verdadero
trabajo empieza el día 28 con el
nombramiento del presidente del
parlamento